you're welcome to this video I am yeah
Geronimo basically and now I'm kind of
that sits like something South American
like Venezuela or something like that
colombia yeah I'm sorry if you are from
Colombia Venezuela I just knew the
general area but I don't know the
precise flags okay 93 and tier 4 why is
that any good it looks weird I had
almost the same thing recently in a game
95 years he's six wins now which I did
not play in that other game that's
strange never expect this to be repeated
Queen a5 is the problem hehe I think he
has to cancel now no okay check to just
make a game out of it I know I'm
threatening to take on b2 and everything
just winced at Winston's of material
the only issues marking not yet
cancelled but the white pieces don't
look like they are extremely dangerous
there should be three event well that's
just one piece on f7
I go 97 and counseling short and then at
the end of it should be five was
stronger hey the app Bishop b5 wasn't
even stronger it this is this is enough
and an ending with the piece up
shouldn't be bad
yeah not much to say he's just dragging
this on white present isn't it strange
that that this line is played like two
times it's really weird yeah 93 and
technology doesn't make all that much
sense here in this position if you don't
have see 3d form the white position is
kind of pointless I mean I'm controlling
this square very very reliably now and
when you play d4 anyway and it's just
does not work it just just blunt as a
pawn for nothing yeah and then here
already is very critical why it has to
go to e2 now and after something like
this I am I am better but it's yeah it's
kind of maybe it's still somewhat
unclear when the engine is basically
saying that this doesn't work either but
it's better than this which immediately
loses yeah check and this is gone I'm
threatening to take with sorry nothing
to take with check your situ or whatever
and then the bishop is under attack plus
there's the threat of sea takes be to
forking so he will lose stuff now and
yeah basically do whatever Bishop b5 is
a little bit stronger yeah that wins the
peace out right it's not really relevant
if you are that much material up until
resigned yeah just d4 just doesn't work
that nine-year with a six Bishop f4 g6
um white should go see 3d for either now
c3 or castles n c3 other lines don't
promise much or nothing ok thanks for
watching